well I think the problems in there
really started during the iraq-iran war
we need to remember that to put the
whole thing into a context Iran actually
had a very good record of looking after
its cultural heritage up until then
probably the best in the whole of the
region but during the war it didn't have
the capacity or the resources to spend
money on conservative monuments and
protecting archaeological sites so they
started to fall into disrepair and these
problems were exacerbated in during the
first Gulf War in 1990 when a number of
provincial museums were ransacked and
some archaeological sites were looted
now unfortunately I think this is all
these are all things that are well known
to many of you unfortunately lessons
were not learned in advance of the
Second Gulf War and coalition troops
failed to take any measures to protect
museums or archaeological sites as is
well known the Iraq museum itself was
looted and some iconic objects such as a
very famous ivory plaque showing a
lioness and an African are still missing
together with about 8,000 or
chips from the storerooms and these
include the Iraq museums unparalleled
collection of cylinder sales and there
was also at that time some looting
although on a much lesser scale in Mosul
Museum at the same time a number of
archaeological sites all in the south of
the country were very bad diluted and
they include places like missing Omaha
root and nipple and photographs of these
sites surfaces pockmarked with holes
rather like a Swiss cheese or a lunar
landscape a one case of attracted a
great deal of attention was Babylon but
the problem here was of a different kind
there was it became the site of a
coalition military base known as camp
alpha when it was occupied by coalition
troops a good deal of damage was done
and that was the subject of a detailed
report published by UNESCO in 2009 so in
sum during this period there was a lot
of damage to Iraqi cultural heritage but
there were also some positive
developments for example a survey of
archaeological sites in southern Iraq in
June 2008 seemed to show that the
looting had more or less stopped by then
and the World Monuments found was given
a grant by the US State Department to
prepare a detailed survey and management
plan for Babylon then the Iraq museum
was able to reopen all its galleries
last summer and progress is being made
with establishing a new museum for Basra
so it did seem by the spring of last
year that some real progress
being maiden that the worst was over I
think few people could have predicted
the absolute disaster that was about to
befall Iran on 10th June as you know
Islamic fundamentalists variously known
as Isis or - overrun Mosul I've not only
introduced a rope but they've been
booked on a program of cultural
destruction these unparalleled in modern
times in Mosul for example in Mosul
itself in the city many famous mosques
and shrines have been obliterated
apparently on the grounds of they
commemorate Saints and other famous
figures which is enough about of the
fundamentalist interpretation of Sunni
Islam so we would buy our Isis and more
than 50 iconic buildings in Mosul have
been destroyed many of them dating back
to the seventh century AD and many of
them of great historical significance
and this widespread destruction has
actually gone largely unnoticed by the
Western media but when we consider that
there were more historical monuments in
Mosul than in any other city in Iraq the
scale of the disaster does start to
become clear well of course a favorite
tactic of Isis is the release of
propaganda videos I expect you've all
seen I understand from Vernon that a
policy was decision a policy decision
was taken not to show any of them
and I agree with that but just to say
that the first one released in late
February showed the Smashing of stone
statues and reliefs in Mosul Museum
there were some Assyrian pieces and some
statues from the caravan city of Petra
and it's unfortunate that early reports
about the damage in Mosul museum
suggested that all the pieces which had
been damaged or some of them were costs
that was certainly not the case of about
fifty pieces in the museum only a half
dozen or so were actually cost so their
disruption is a very significant loss
for our cultural heritage and it's a
tragic loss for future generations of
visitors to Mosul Museum and that same
video shows fanatics
attacking Assyrian human-headed winged
Bulls in the Navigator nanofy I'm not
proposing to say anything about Nimrod a
horrific video released last Saturday
showed you
the very very extensive damage that has
been aptly at the site and anybody who
heard Li the strength to watch the video
through to the end will see that the
site of the Northwest Paula Sasha not
spells Palace Saloon rubies nothing more
now a pile of rubble I don't want to
speculate too much here about the
motivation of those involved in this
awful cultural vandalism but in recent
in the recent year in the last year the
sale of Antiquities doesn't seem to
agree in high on the list of priorities
as if it was presumably the these
hooligans wouldn't have been smashing
them well I just like to conclude very
briefly by suggesting a few things that
might be done I know it's the subject of
this afternoon's session but I just like
to very briefly touch on this now in my
own view the most important thing is the
United Nations UNESCO and the
international community should put
pressure on those individuals and
governments who are thought to be
sponsoring Isis pressure on them to stop
supplying money and facilitating what
they're doing but also to issue
statements condemning these actions
the second thing to be dominus is
obvious it's a given which is to enforce
existing read regulations and
legislation about the trafficking of
of Antiquities as I said I don't think
that's been the motivation for this
recent disruption but it's certainly
true that the looting of archaeological
sites from 2003 onwards was was was in
order to attain antiquities for sale on
the market the third thing to be done I
think this is obvious to everybody is to
is more education about the value of
cultural heritage inside and outside the
country confusing question and the
fourth thing is to for the international
community to provide assistance but I
have to say this is more difficult if
and when the Iraq government does
recover the occupied areas is going to
need both sums of money to tackle the
problems on an army of architectural
conservators restorers and so on a huge
international relief effort will
obviously be needed thank you